[Music]
super villains
[Music]
sad cells and costumes wanting you to
think they're all
dark and deep what's the like
living life as a punchline
but all i would take would be one
blessed act of rebellion
for you to restore your dignity in its
entirety
[Music]
you know the deal complete the mission
you get 10 years off your sentence
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
i love him or hate him these are your
brothers and sisters for the next few
days
any questions and yes
that is your hand very good we're all
gonna die
i hope so oh for god's sake
this is suicide that's kind of our thing
like a bloodbath to start the day
they call you peacemaker
i cherish peace with all my heart i
don't care how many men women and
children i need to kill to get it
i thought i am
here's the deal we failed a mission you
died we find out any information you
give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die what no
you